in today's video we'll be explaining the
whole jujutsu kaizen story in only 10
minutes no time to waste let's get
started history of curses emotions are
always important no matter where you go
but they are especially important in the
jujutsu kaizen world negative emotions
create cursed energy and sometimes when
the emotions build up they create cursed
spirits curses have existed since the
dawn of time and reached their peak
during the hayan era when the king of
curses ryoman sukuna was born sukuna was
a human sorcerer that strayed down the
wrong path and killed many sorcerers
from the golden age of jiujitsu after
his death sukuna became a cursed spirit
so strong that his body could not be
fully destroyed the 20 remaining fingers
of sukuna were sealed and kept preserved
throughout the years as cursed objects
they continue to grow in power every day
humans with tremendous amounts of
negative energy are capable of seeing
cursed spirits which normal humans
cannot see these humans are trained as
sorcerers to better control their cursed
energy and use it to eliminate curses
and protect humanity gojo's past arc
over the years the curses have gotten
much stronger but some of the sorcerers
with the next generation being
exceptionally stronger specifically two
sorcerers satoru gojo and suguru ghetto
in 2006 these two sorcerers are just
second-year students and are given an
important mission to escort the star
plasma vessel to an immortal sorcerer
master tengan tenkan's immortality
demands that he change his body every
500 years or there's a huge risk of him
bringing harm to humanity therefore the
young sorcerers leave to find the vessel
and safely escort her back the two
groups start to target the vessel with
one of them hiring the notorious
sorcerer killer toshi zenin toji's lack
of cursed energy allows him to instantly
beat the talented sorcerers and fulfill
his mission of killing the vessel as
well however the fight doesn't stop
there as gojo surpasses his limits to
beat toji unleashing a rare ability
known by very few in the gojo family the
hollow purple technique before dying
toji mentions his son megumifushiguru to
gojo and how he sold him off to the
zenon family a year later while satori
was thriving in the jujutsu world as the
strongest known sorcerer suguru feels
isolated and questions his purpose as a
sorcerer he begins to think less of
non-sorcerer humans ghetto reaches his
breaking point when he goes on a mission
and witnesses two young sorcerers being
locked up and brutally treated by the
villagers ghetto decides to join the
dark side and eliminate all
non-sorcerers satoru on the other hand
disheartened by his best friend's
actions goes to luck for megumi and
decides that he won't let megami walk
down the same path chris childhark fast
forward to 2016 gojo is teaching in
tokyo jiu-jitsu high and comes across a
special human yuda okatsu as a child
you'd have fell in love with riko
orimoto and both promised to get married
once they were older however rika died
in the traffic accident and became a
vengeful spirit after a particular grave
incident with yoda's bullies gojo finds
yoda and gives him a chance to become a
jiu jitsu sorcerer and control rika's
powers due to the unique nature of
yura's abilities and his unmatched
strength ghetto takes an interest in him
and announces an attack on shinjuku and
kyoto suguru uses the attack as a
distraction and confronts you to alone
in tokyo jujutsu high effectively
defeating his classmates seeing this
yuda loses control and fights against
ghetto revealing his ability to copy
other curse techniques as a final resort
yuta frees rika and promises to spend
his entire life with her which removes
the limits on her power allowing you to
effectively defeat ghetto forcing him to
retreat ghetto dies at the hands of gojo
but an ancient sorcerer known as kanjaku
reanimates him planting his brain into
ghetto's corpse and taking over his body
introduction arc a year later
megamifushiguru is on a mission to look
for a special great cursed object he
comes across yuji and adori a student
possessing extraordinary physical
abilities and is in the cult group who
also happens to have the sealed sukuna
finger yuji's friends accidentally
unseal the object attracting strong
curses to their location megami and yuji
try to fight them off but are backed
into a corner and yuji is forced to eat
the cursed object to gain enough power
to save everyone sukuna possesses yuji's
body and beats the curse with one hit
however sukuna is unable to overpower or
even land a hit on the invincible gojo
satoru what's more yuji is the only one
capable of holding back sukuna and is
given the opportunity to find the
remaining fingers and eliminate them
once and for all yuji gladly agrees and
becomes gojo's student later meeting up
with two of his classmates megami
fujiguru and ubarakugisaki gocha sends
yuji and nobara on a mission to exercise
curses and roppongi and both do an
incredible job cursed womark two weeks
later while gojo was away the trio was
sent on an emergency mission to a
detention center where a cursed woman
has appeared unfortunately when they
arrive the cursed womb has already
created the special great curse that has
massacred everyone at the facility
nobara gets separated from the group and
yuji forces megami to look for her and
leave so he can let sukuna out and
defeat the curse sukuna easily beats the
curse with his domain expansion yuji is
unable to regain control making sukuna
run free and take his body as a hostage
by ripping his heart out megumi fight
sukuna and yuji regains consciousness
just in time but he ends up dying cursed
training arc following yuji's death sudo
ghetto jogo and tony meet up to discuss
the next course of action meanwhile
megumi and nabarra are saddened over the
death of their friend megumi and nabarro
get bullied by aoi toto and mai zenen
who are senior students at the kyoto
high school upon returning gojo learns
about yuji's death and blames the higher
ups for it at the same time sukuna and
yuji form a binding vow and as a result
yuji is resurrected goju decides to keep
this a secret and personally trains yuji
gojo then uses his fight with joko to
demonstrate how domain expansions work
versus mojito arc yuji continues his
training with anatomy a first grade
sorcerer who is not very fond of his job
both leave on a mission to investigate
transfigured human corpses which were
the work of a cursed spirit named mojito
a young high schooler juniperino is
dragged in by mohito who manipulates him
and darkens his thoughts about humans
the sorcerers find out about junpei
being a witness and yuji becomes good
friends with him mojito kills juniper's
mother further manipulating him and
changing him into a cursed spirit yuji
fights june bay convincing him to stop
and ask him to help him to which the
king of curses coldly refuses mojito
tries to impress sukuna but fails badly
and almost dies but before yuji anonymi
could finish him off mohito escapes and
recovers underground kyoto goodwill
event after the mission yuji makes his
return with gojo just in time for the
kyoto goodwill event however nobara and
megumi aren't too happy to be held in
the dark about the true situation what's
more yuji is targeted again by the
higher ups but this time the kyoto high
school students are ordered to kill him
the battle between the two schools
begins and the students give their all
maki and mai remove their
misunderstanding while toto and yuji
bond over their similar taste in women
and become best friends however the
event is interrupted by mojito's group
laying a barrier that only forbids gojo
from entering the area of the event
meanwhile the sorcerers tried to hold
back the special greater spiritonomy but
failed to deal much damage toto and yuji
put up a great fight against sonomy
working as if they've known each other
for years the barrier breaks and gojo
enters the area smoothly taking out the
invaders using this hollow purple
technique on hanami from far away which
he barely manages to escape from death
painting arc afterward the trio was
assigned another mission revolving
around the mysterious deaths occurring
in megami's former school the sorcerers
find that megami's sister's condition
and the deaths might be linked to the
yasuhachi bridge megami manages to
exercise the curse under the bridge but
finds another curse hidden bearing one
of sukuna's fingers the special grid
curse proves to be quite powerful
forcing megami to surpass his limits and
unleash his domain expansion nobara and
yuji also put up a great fight using the
black flash together the trio manages to
complete the mission successfully with
sukuna forcefully eating one of his
fingers to gain more power shibuya
incident arc a few days later the first
year students meet with udahime who
informs them about a certain mole
operating with mojito's group
kukichimuta as the trio investigates the
situation kokichi meets up with mojito
and sudo ghetto to remove the
restriction on his body mojito decides
to kill him instead starting a fight
between the two kokichi uses all his
techniques on mojito who barely manages
to get away after killing the mekumaru
user on halloween october 31st sudo
ghetto works with other cursed spirits
and cursed users to seal satoru gojo
once and for all a massive barrier is
cast around shibuya with the residents
inside calling for gojo to help the
jujutsu sorcerers try to look for the
cursed users behind the multiple screens
around the area satoru gojo enters the
shibuya station and fights against the
special great curses gojo easily
exercises hanami in the train full of
mutated humans that arrives with mojito
however sudo ghetto appears shocking
gojo and distracting him enough to steal
him in the prison realm sudo ghetto then
reveals his identity and gojo tries to
appeal to the remnants of ghetto's
consciousness left in the body before
dying kokichi had made arrangements to
communicate and guide the jiu jitsu
sorcerers during his period and informed
them of gojo being sealed takuma ino a
second grade sorcerer fights against
ogimi and her grandson takuma tries to
hold them off but okami's grandson trips
forms into toji's zenin and easily beats
them toji takes over the body and then
kills okami as well the jiujitsu
sorcerers enter the station and fight
against the cursed wound that has
evolved into daggen dagon is extremely
strong and the sorcerers struggled to
defeat him till doji appears and
single-handedly defeats him without much
trouble choji then starts to fight with
megami realizing later that he is
fighting his son and so he kills himself
jogo appears and attacks the sorcerers
badly wounded maki and nanami yuji
enters shibuya station and fights
against cho so who knocks him out but
doesn't kill him due to some false
memory in his mind yuji has then fed two
of sukuna's fingers in his unconscious
state while gojo forcefully gives him
the remaining 10 to bring sukuna out an
epic fight breaks between sukuna and
jogo but tsukuna comes out unscathed and
exercises jogo with flame manipulation
technique sakuna then heads towards
megumi who's just learning the powerful
ten shadows technique and to summon
general maharaga sekuna fights against
maharaga one of the strongest shikigami
and barely manages to beat it sukuna
then switches with yuji who breaks down
thinking that he'll be executed soon but
his pain doesn't end there as majito
kills nami and nobara to further break
his soul toto appears just in time to
save his best friend and snaps yuji back
to normal sudo ghetto suddenly appears
absorbing mojito and revealing the
binding vows he had made with the
strongest sorceress from a millennium
ago joseph realizes the true identity of
sudo ghetto and becomes yuji's older
brother edithori's extermination arc
meanwhile the execution is given for
ghetto yuji and yakamasamichi unsealing
gojo is declared to be a serious
criminal act as he is considered an
accomplice in the shibuya incident yudo
gatsu returns and is made responsible
for executing yuji yudha fakes his death
as per gojo's request and supports yuji
due to their similar circumstances
megami asks yuji to help him save his
sister assault curse users have been
made part of the culling game the
jujutsu sorcerers visit master tangen to
discuss the current situation of the
culling game and ask him about unsealing
gojo master tangent shares his role in
the upcoming battle royale and mentions
hanukkah russo who can unseal gojo with
her curse technique meanwhile maki uses
megami's authority as head of the clan
to enter the zenith household brutally
killing all of the members and beating
up nawaya zenin with maki's mother
dealing the final blow yuji and megumi
enter the underground fight club to
recruit a suspended jiu-jitsu sorcerer
kinji hikari tokyo number one colony arc
now the culling game has begun dividing
japan into nine colonies yuji and megami
are heading towards the first colony to
find a powerful lawyer named hiromi
higuruma both sorcerers managed to
overcome the obstacles in their path and
guiche also convinces higuraman to save
him his 100 points however this is only
the beginning of the death match between
all sorcerers around japan and nobody
knows what pseudogatto hopes to gain
from all the massacre check out this
video where we explain the entire demon
slayer story in only 10 minutes